you should have listened Mormon father
spoke about the importance of gold I
know it's boring for you you just wanted
to hunt and ride and fight but I
listened I learned my garden waters the
most powerful army and esos the golden
company 20,000 men horses elephants I
believe the golden company is not here
they're in Essos how is a mercenary
company in SS going to help us do you
really think you're in gradua turned
tail and sail back to the Iron Islands
do you think he abandoned the chance to
marry the Queen no one walks away from
me he's sailing with his fleet to Essos
he's going to ferry the golden company
back here to help us win the war for
Westeros
hey everyone you requested a golden
company video they're a really cool
group of mercenaries from the book
there's a big storyline that they might
be including from the TV show so I'm
gonna explain why it's relevant to Jon
Snow's storyline and why it's so
important for a Circe's storyline
because she says no one ever walks away
from me just remember that in the motto
of the golden company is our word is as
good as gold as in they've never broken
a contract so as far as she thinks
Cersei has this ace in the hole
an ironclad contract that Euron's
helping her execute thanks to the iron
bank so if you're finding me for the
first time this is just one of many
season eight videos that we're gonna be
talking about in the off season so be
sure to subscribe to get everything and
there's giveaway stuff that I'll talk
about at the end of the video but the
cool thing about the golden company is
they're essentially a mercenary group
started by Targaryen bastards made up of
exiled Westerosi Lords so if you're like
Sir Jorah and you're exiled for whatever
reason usually that's where you go to
find work because if you're a knight and
you're exiled you have crazy good skills
because even though the TV show didn't
show it off a whole lot Sir Jorah was an
anointed Knight as they actually called
out during season seven so he had crazy
good skills even though he's a little
bit older on the TV show now so we're
seeing him later in his life although he
did show some mad skills up beyond the
wall during episode six but the whole
thing about the golden company is that
they're just a lot more trustworthy than
the other cell sword companies my hand
kybun has made overtures to the golden
company in Essos I know them well they
have helped us recover a significant
sums from parties who would fall into
deep arrears it's good to hear I too
would like them to recover some things
that belong to me but as ty CONUS
tourist tells Cersei they use them they
trust them and if the iron bank trusts
someone to execute a contract it means
that they are legit but in the books we
don't really meet any golden company
characters until feast for crows book
four and there's a lot of Dorne plot
that gets tied up with it so obviously
the TV shows gonna do a slightly
different version and they don't
specifically mention that Jorah was a
member of the golden company but you may
remember that season four moment where
Daenerys calls him out it's not a
question
approval is a question of trust you
neither approve nor trust well I would
hire them as a cell sort didn't you
fight for the golden company before
pledging your sword to my brother I did
I trust you
there are a couple really important book
characters that the TV show has cut out
or given storylines to other characters
that we meet through them Jon connington
and Aegon otherwise known as young grip
so you have these golden company
characters that surface in Arianne
Martell who's one of the door and
characters the TV show has cut out gets
word that they've broken their contract
their unbreakable contracts get broken
because they're turning to support a
Gon's bid for the throne so he's sort of
like this new contender that comes out
of nowhere with this seemingly perfect
backstory so it all sounds a little too
good to be true but you have all these
exiled Westerosi Lords including Jon
connington
who was Rhaegar Targaryen 'he's
childhood friend he was his best friend
growing up
so when Rhaegar died because jon
connington supported the crown during
Robert's rebellion he was exiled he went
and joined the golden company there in
the middle of this campaign in Essos
they drop everything they're doing and
then head to Westeros and they're
getting ready to take storms and in the
books so they're right there next to the
Crown lands so it's just another example
of a couple different campaigns for
people to take the Iron Throne on the TV
show you just have Daenerys you have
Cersei and then obviously we have the
surprise that Jon Snow is Aegon
Targaryen so here's where we get into
theory territory
remember that Aegon Targaryen is part of
the golden company in the books they say
screw you to the people that hired them
breaking their unbreakable contracts to
back a Gon's bid for the throne jon
connington one of the leaders of the
golden company got part of his storyline
from the books given to Sir Jorah who
used to be part of the golden company on
the TV show it was a grayscale plot Jon
connington gets greyscale Jorah gets
greyscale obviously the TV show had a
really weird storyline with jurors
greyscale I think that was really just a
reason for him to not be around tenaris
there were some scheduling conflicts
with the actors so they're like okay
we'll give him this greyscale plot from
Jon connington and we'll put him on the
sidelines for a couple episodes then
he'll come back to Daenerys so because
there are all
these TV show things that are seemingly
lining up with book things for the
golden company people are now wondering
if they're going to break their contract
on the TV show with Cersei in Bac Jon
Snow and Daenerys you just have to
remember there are only six episodes in
season eight so I'm not expected to see
them introduce any really really big
black fire characters they'll probably
be some verbal references to their
family their lineage so once they learn
the truth of what's going on with
Daenerys and the son of Rhaegar
Targaryen somebody who they really loved
then in the way that you've seen the
Dothraki support Daenerys we might see
the golden company's support them now
think about it this way how big are the
Dothraki characters during season seven
they were very important we got to see
some really badass scenes like Episode
four was an amazing Dothraki scene but
how many of them are like really fleshed
out characters now like how many big
lines of dialogue they're more like
menacing characters in the background
you see them step up when Jon Snow tries
to approach the throne they're meant to
be very threatening but none of them get
really big character moments they just
get big battle scenes so I wouldn't be
surprised if they treat the golden
company characters the same way like
we're they're really badass like you see
gray worm in the finale it's just like a
very brief moment you see all these
unsullied legions lined up it looks
super badass but we're so late in the
game that you just don't expect too many
new big characters to get a lot of big
moments but if the golden company is
gonna betray Cersei there's a number of
ways that they could choose to
accomplish that and have a couple of
character moments like Sir Jorah talks
to them and they believe that Daenerys
will give them back their titles in
their lands if they help her out so in
the books they really do love this Aegon
Targaryen character but part of the idea
is is that they're exiled Westerosi
Lords they want to come home they want
to be pardoned in Daenerys once she's on
the throne can do that for them or even
John depending on who you think's gonna
wind up on the Iron Throne and because
so many people are gonna die during
season eight just think about all the
empty castles of Westeros this sort of a
running joke on the TV show right now
like when they rolled up to Dragonstone
in the first episode it was empty this
huge strategic position which is
completely empty storm's end is
completely empty right now even
Highgarden
is completely empty there are so many
castles just ripe for the taking for all
these exiled Westerosi Lords to come
back if they want them but let me know
in the comments do you think because Sir
Jorah got the Jon connington plot in the
books it because Aegon the person in the
books that the golden company breaks
their contract to support is now sort of
Jon Snow on the TV show do you think
that they'll simplify golden company on
the TV show and just have them break
their contract with Cersei to go add to
Daenerys as forces as they're fighting
the night king remember that line of
dialogue from Cersei this is sort of her
tag line now no one walks away from me
then what happens right after that Jaime
just walks right away he covers up his
golden hand although that's mostly for
winter protection because it's really
cold and because he doesn't want people
on the road seeing him identifying him
as Jaime Lannister in trying to kill him
or steal everything from him there is a
Jaime video that I was planning on
making so why don't I just do that
tomorrow I'll talk about his season 8
plot because there's so much awesome
brand reunion stuff that I'm excited
about Jaime and bran in the same room
again Jaime and Brienne Jaime and pretty
much everybody up at Winterfell
but hopefully that explains TV show
golden company a little bit in how they
might rope in some old book plot that
they've already skipped over the whole
thing with the black fires the history
bittersteel
I'm not expecting them to dig too deep
into that because they've only talked
briefly about the black fires they
haven't referenced the Blackfyre
rebellion that much but we can talk
about black fires golden company bitter
steel daemon Blackfyre in a future bonus
video so let me know if you want me to
do that in the comments there's a bunch
of stuff coming up too so make sure you
click the bell to enable alerts for my
channel so you don't miss anything and
I'll say congratulations to the last
giveaway winner
Mario Andre please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details while you wait for
everything click here for my new clue
game Bowl video and you can click here
for my other season 8 videos thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you